kayla
she is
one of if not the greatest american
judoka ever
uh two-time gold medalist
2010 world champion 2010 for senior
worlds senior worlds
what makes kayla
special what makes her so great
what made this champion
it's a combination of of
a lot of things one was obviously
kayla's mental toughness right to
overcome what she overcame
you know this is a girl who
you know let
let's i don't say forget about the
sexual abuse but the the fact that she
had to go through that in life and and
learned how to compartmentalize that and
keep that off as a separate part of her
brain you know and forget about it and
move on
that took an incredible team to help her
do that and my dad was a huge part of
her
accomplishing that so for people who
don't know we should comment and say
that kayla had to go through trauma
in her earlier life
through sexual abuse and had to overcome
that through the whole process of
of becoming a champion as well right
because she had zero self-esteem zero
self-worth she was at the lowest of lows
and and
um
you know didn't even want to be on this
earth right so she she was traumatized
obviously for
and getting her the right help and
surrounding her with the right people
who could help her get through that and
and be by her side as she's getting
through that and letting her know and
reaffirming that she's doing the right
thing and she made the right decision
and she should have zero guilt and
you know this doesn't define her it
happened to her but it doesn't define
her what defines her is what she does
from now on and then rebuilding that
person to become who she became i think
the mental toughness is is a big part of
it her her mind
um
but then
as an athlete
you know she's a lot like travis
you know she's she's a warrior she's a
fighter you know my dad always jokes
with her you know
he says you're a workhorse you're not a
thoroughbred we're not going to treat
you like a thoroughbred right you're a
workhorse so you're going to work and
the way you're going to get bigger and
stronger is going to work harder and
you're going to keep you know and she
came to us when she was only 15. so
at that time we got her with a really
good strength and conditioning coach we
did all the core olympic style lifting
like as her body was developing
she was getting stronger every single
day and then you know she had the luxury
of being on the mat with
at the time i was still young enough to
train and be on the mat and i was around
her weight class and travis was able to
train with her and all we had all the
top us athletes at the time
training here at my school so she got
the benefit of all the best guys to
train within the country you know and
and her doing all of those rounds
you know night in week
night every night every week every year
compiled with the best you know highest
level she could as a girl
she got the strength she got the
technique she got the and then she had
the coaching on top of it with my dad
being on her as you know working her out
and you know having the
the wherewithal to develop a strategy
and a plan for her because when she
first came here
she competed at 63 kilos which is 138
pounds
at the time
ronda was ronda rousey was also training
here and she was 70 kilos so if kayla
was struggling making 63. so the only
way to obviously the only way to still
compete is to move up
but my dad said well if you move up then
you're in rhonda's weight so let's skip
that wait you're going to go to 78 kilos
and he told her listen you're going to
go up two way classes
she looked at him and was like that's
172 pounds and he goes well i don't care
like you're already struggling making
138 you weigh 150 what's the difference
we put 20 pounds on go to 170. so that's
why she jumped two weights because she
passed rhonda
she went to the weight above so she
could make the national team and she had
a chance to go to the olympics and and
all that because we envisioned ronda
staying around until 2012. and that's
also like a long-term vision because you
kind of grow into that body then over
time correct so you can dominate you can
learn what it's like in that weight
class you can learn to dominate that
weight classic excel and then dominate
people that cut weight too hard too long
they forget about technique because
they're only worried about losing weight
they're always tired in training they
don't give a hundred percent effort
they're not getting better she now is
just focused on getting better at judo
you know and getting bigger getting
stronger getting more powerful so i
think giving her that purpose and that
that was a great call
what are some memorable or maybe the
most memorable moment kayla harrison
moment to you as her coach
not the most perhaps let's say
what are some memorable moments
everybody hears the good ones right so
everybody knows she won the war she won
the world championships in tokyo in 2012
in 2010 she was our two-time olympic
champion in 2012 2016. i'll never forget
those moments right because they're
historic
one of the biggest moments that i like
sharing this story with everybody is
that
in 2010 in january
kayla was still a developing athlete and
we had a local tournament in new york
it was in brooklyn new york it was
called the starrett cup
and i knew that at that tournament that
two of the canadian girls they were like
ranked 15th or 20th in the world they
weren't superstars but they were tough
players
both of them i knew were going to be at
that tournament so i said kayla we're
going to go to this tournament you're
going to compete against the canadian
girls get some good experience you know
figure out what you need to work on and
then we'll go home and work on some
stuff
well she went to the tournament there
was only three girls in the weight her
and the two canadians
at that tournament
she lost both fights
right so this is january 2010.
she lost both matches you know she was
competitive but certainly things she
needed to work on it was good you know
development thing for her and for us it
also opened her mind to say oh man you
know because she was already uh
a junior world champion at the time but
so now there's another level this is a
senior level right you got to go up on
another level here's two girls that
aren't even medalists that are beating
you so now there's more work to be done
and so i like telling that story because
everybody sees the champions and the
greatest moments they don't see them
when they have bad days and could you
imagine being you know owen two
you feel like you feel like a failure
right but
10 months later
it was tokyo 2010 she went from owen 2
at starrett new york
to world champion 2010 in the motherland
in japan yeah i mean that's an amazing
turnaround
and that's only possible if you put the
losses in their proper context
you don't let it destroy you mentally
and just keep moving forward
correct this is so funny uh so you were
there at 2010 at the stair cup
was travis there
yeah i made all those we fought at every
lo like the mentality of our team was no
tournament is beneath us if our goal is
to go to the olympics in the worlds and
win
there's no tournament that's beneath us
we're going to get experience we're
going to fight we're going to learn
we're going to compete we're going to
get better
you know
i actually just as a funny little con
side i was there i competed really this
is one of the earlier tournaments like
the beginner division oh no i actually
did black belt division too
that was one of the actually yeah i
remember that that's when it was so
early that i thought
like i was also really strong at that
time just like physically like
powerlifting stuff so i thought like it
would be good experience uh to also do
uh black belt division and remember
it must have been actually travis's
division which is funny uh
uh there's legere brothers
yeah harry and gary they are super
they're super good and they're super
dominant but i think travis faced one of
them
and beat them
um i i don't know i just remembered uh
it's funny how there's just like these
little roads that later
reconnect right uh but yeah there's some
incredible people there
and it i saw obviously the positive
things and it's interesting that kayla's
story was also intersecting there and
that was one of the lower points for her
another story i like to to share is that
you have to know your athletes right and
you have to you know really get to know
their psychological what they're
thinking psychologically mentally what's
going through their head another
story was in in tokyo it was
to tokyo grand slam
so we had
had kayla face off against almost all
the top girls in her in her division she
had beaten everybody going into the 2016
olympics but at the 2015
tokyo grand slam
there was a girl from japan that she
hadn't fought in a long time and she
lost her girl last time she she fought
her so it was something we wanted her to
beat this girl going into the olympics
so that she knew she could beat
everybody
and it was a first round match
and
it was gonna be tough for kayla right it
was gonna be a really hard fight and
she had won a bunch of tournaments in a
row leading up to that so her confidence
was really high but at the same time
she didn't think she needed this fight
and she showed up to the tournament and
she said
i don't think i can fight today i've got
a stinger in my neck you know i've got a
stinger coming down my neck and i'm kind
of sore and
she didn't tell us she went and told the
trainer she walked around she's holding
her neck and me and my dad were like
what's up with her
and then so
like maybe she doesn't want to fight
today i don't know right so
all of a sudden the trainer comes up to
us and she didn't come to us the trainer
came to us you know i really don't think
it's a good idea that kayla fight today
i mean we looked at him and like
well your opinion doesn't really matter
does it okay like
what's up with her yeah oh she has this
thing in her neck it's like a pinched
nerve and there's this and then
we talked i said
is there a risk of her getting injured
like is this pain or is this risk that
she's going to get injured and she's
going to set her back like long time in
her career
she says no she's not going to get
injured she's just a pinched nerve a
little pain she's going to have to deal
with i go okay well can you fix the pain
he says yeah i can do this and that and
i can give her a shot and the pain will
go away
okay then do that
and so kayla kayla comes up she goes
didn't the trainer talk to you i said
yeah he talked to us well he said i
can't fight
i know but we already talked to the
trainer and
i love it he said you're good to go yeah
she looked at us like
and then we had to talk to her and say
listen
you're not injured you're in pain
because we just came from a camp i said
you're in pain but here's the deal we
want you to fight this girl why don't
you go out there and beat this girl
period i don't care i want to know that
you can beat this girl this is why we
came this is our last
hard tournament before the olympic games
this is what you what we want from you
and lo and behold she understood she
they gave her a quick shot the rest of
the world thought we were crazy making
her compete yeah
and then she went out there she fought
didn't even know she was injured no you
know what i mean she just went out there
she fought the tournament she beat the
japanese girl she ended up going through
the whole tournament she took a gold
medal
she won the event
yeah it turned out to be a great
confidence builder in it
yeah
uh and that kind of sets you up for all
the chaos that can happen at the olympic
games and it tells you if you can beat
these girls when you're not a hundred
percent yeah and you're not at your best
you're physically beat mentally beat
imagine what you're gonna do when you're
fresh well when she was going to the
olympic games there's a lot she had the
mental game down down down there wasn't
a girl in that division that thought
that could be kayla going into those
games not a one
they just looked at her and went no not
happening yeah
that's great i mean she's a great
olympic champion two-time olympic
champion
you